hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with yamimash hello hello
and we finally got Killing Floor 2 work
it's been a bit of a problem hmm
not our fault not our fault it was game
that was being silly and stupid but
anyway you guys have requested a lot of
killing floor so we finally decided to
get going so we are going to play it on
normal and a medium link thing so let's
go I'm ready I'm at command ID I'm ready
I'm a Support Specialists as you can
tell we're not very experienced at this
game we're both level zero
oh hey hmm hey how's it going not so bad
it's awfully red in here dude we've been
cooking I don't know all right I found
some ammo really yeah
sorry I'm just a little excited happy to
finally get this to work what was that
what that what I heard a noise oh you
Dom B's forget Holloway I'm shooting you
how did shoot me let's stop running in
the way then please we need to work
together cuz quato my god slow motion oh
that's awesome
yeah yeah neither yamimash nor I have
played this very much I've just been
decking around a bit
hmm oh the trade is to oaken's me for
some reason
yeah the trader is out in between rounds
you will go buy stuff and things
ahh oh god what my day okay Oh No ah
if you blow up their heads they don't
die really that's hardly fair hey there
oh the same more types will come out in
the next few rounds this is Jenny's E
begin around is that right
yeah sorry maybe I don't know it's dirt
ain't hugging on this yeah right mouse
button oh that right behind us yeah oh
shut up mature the big one
I think the big ones explode into a
shower of acid or something
whoa there we go we're here nah I go to
achievement
so did I not easy being greasy I don't
know what that's right we did it
ah hey we're the best now I go to the
traitor and buy some more guns you know
I'm a support which is supposed to well
doors but there doesn't seem to be any
doors here I'm just a guy that does
shooting I'm a commander huh I shoot too
I shoot there oh yeah oh yeah you
probably do this the right way yeah
follow the glowy's and it'll take you to
this shop oh just come in here to my
bunker oh okay this is oh here we go
right here Oh Trainor
oh hello baby what do I get oh no pull
up a bullpup what's a bullpup it's a gun
it shoots stuff all right I'm getting it
I am I got a shotgun oh really
yeah but I'm a shotgun specialist you're
a commando I think your assault rifle
person uh-oh see oh no I didn't buy in
time
ha ha ha I'm just gonna oh you mean
attack you I become Ayame you're gonna
die oh don't die
I got your back got him look Crawley
ones dude you're supposed to be a
support heal me you got a med kit I
think or at least you should press Q
what the hell got a rocket launcher are
you short like a sa-do's ah they're
close ah
you da ah you're not gay I hear there's
a death trap for dead oh good one no way
we lost yeah cuz you got stuck in the
damn tunnel Oh Shiva okay anyway
supposed to sorry man that we need to
get out the tunnel will just be
self-explanatory oh we're done your dirt
all right whatever
okay that was that was a practice round
oh it switched the map for us that was
nice of it ah right okay back in I guess
let's do this man now Yahoo mash you
gotta go out of store quickly buy
whatever you need to buy and then get
out okay okay yeah I think I know okay
there are actually doors in this one
that I can weld up for extra defense hey
Doc God look behind you line noise
little guy give me a hug I don't think
you should ask these for hugs yeah uh it
didn't work out well for us last time so
let's just not
I kind of pop out of nowhere Oh a break
through the windows and [ __ ]
uh-huh I got this one no I don't
reloading hide your kids hide your wife
unload on oh I got behind your back
I got him I'm on I got I got everything
back covered you shoot down the [ __ ] way
yeah yeah I'm just I'm just gonna shoot
everything and I'm gonna shoot you in
the back of the head apparently total
accident
I keep to that you're welcome we're in
trouble
I'll Road trouble just show dammit I'm
running out of ammo this is not gonna
turn out very well where are they coming
from
I don't know like I said they pop out of
everywhere
oh man and just three left another
strategy is to preemptively get close to
the traitor before the round ends oh no
way I need to reload reload heads flow
[ __ ] okay so we got a the traitor is
down here so we can kind of just stand
move I found a shotgun no way yeah I'm
stopping this guy no I shot shotgun come
here since I already bought a shotgun
here have some ammo or money thank you
really welcome I'm such a grateful
person I'm going follow the red hair oh
okay what's up wise wait it's 10 meters
below why do we need to go that way I
don't know
are you Amish Chuck it's me quick yeah
xxx
we ain't screwing up this time oh I'm
not I don't know about you I know your
father last time that was not okay cuz
beans down here sounds like a death trap
okay I need to be quick here I'm gonna
buy a or flame from her yes also
apparently you run faster with the knife
be hurry
fifteen targets we got a guy here man
then I'm done I'm done this guy
okay so we need to find it come in here
come in here come in here coming come in
here okay I'm gonna close this and I'm
gonna weld it up okay yeah
I'll call you back okay yes god I'm so
strategically awesome
you are very shmatte okay that's not
gonna hold for long
so uh I'm sure okay okay you check it
and I'll keep this one locked up okay
don't worry nothing is getting through
me are you sure about that
100% MA don't worry you can put your
trust in me okay this one's this one
pretty well okay this one's pretty
welded up so we should be good for
something
all right now worry I've got this slide
it yeah right I got your back bro hey
Emma
yeah you're out of ammo yeah look out
behind you I mean ma I've tried oh maybe
it wasn't such a good idea to be stuck
in here this is about oh no we gotta
wait two three there no they're fine
doors gonna hold oh gosh show them [ __ ]
no harder are you out of ammo switched
your pistol
I got a block out the door again welcome
to duel but I got it I got it guys fine
it fun I got it jog on the run man heal
quick press Q here whoo whoo I got
what
well you're bad at this game oh not bad
haha you can't kill me a 2-0 I'm too bro
ah get away get away get away get away
hold door god damn gonna help that door
holds when do I restored I don't know
maybe at the next round go look at that
oh I'm so pro
oh god I'm the greatest ever give it see
ya
it she you'll up again oh yes feels so
good mmm
okay maybe get a quarter did this room
was not a good idea after this we will
fun different bit and you need haha me
whoa what do I eat huh hello mark are
you what are you alive meet me at the
trader
well I oh there you are it's good don't
die this I wanted you to just Sheena
show off yeah yeah okay Oh some ammo on
the trades like news every time yep
makes it a bit more complicated remember
to fill up on ammo I need like I need
some better than just a pistol and a
shotgun because the pot shotgun oh I
don't have any money huh I have no money
well I have some money but not enough
money and I'm gonna buy combat armor as
well hello my friends I'm yesterday
shooting the 9-millimeter tactical are
you being FPSRussia right now did you
know cuz sounded like it but what other
youtuber does that no one exactly
because of my British accent you won't
be out to town I thought you were doing
a British version over Russia this looks
like a big open place so we could work
where'd you go yami yup hello-o their
cars Jesus ok so actually there's some
ammo in here - over there that green
glowing things
Mac Shama what's that from
well God Maxim mmm erase it hi there
invisible was i invisible
yeah they're kind of invisible you ah
where are they coming from they're
coming over this barrier here yeah just
keep shooting we got this oh my oh my
ass stop typing things in chat I don't
know why I'm doing that
before I would I would always go sue
okay you're okay you're okay it's all
good in this neighborhood
oh man that was good that was good good
[ __ ] that oh they're coming from above
that's why look Rob Ando huh I got it
cleared him out dude dude I just
headshot him oh no no you're gonna die
no why do you keep leaving me but dummy
picked up a second pistol
apparently so badass look at me go oh hi
Jam - thank you thank you had my back
man it's all your fault okay alright
yeah okay does my fault it was you guys
are ugly ah they're also a lot of them
so it's like give me a kiss
we're doing something wrong here which
is easy man this is on normal I mean
there are a lot more difficult ones in
this hang on let me look at these
specialists again by my highest level is
a level 2 and that's a sharpshooter
Zeca support doesn't seem to be doing
much oh I like the Sharpshooter he seems
calm I'm gonna be him I'll be him - I
guess maybe this all this will help us
doesn't change the field yeah better
pistol dammit better all-round damage on
everything okay I'm ready I'm ready -
all right hello I played this one before
I didn't do too well no
what helicopter just left us there
oh yeah well that's cuz we're
specialists highly trained professionals
trial English yeah that's my mommy Oh
slow motion it's very level of them like
walk up some and talk to them you do
that lovely camera you know I've come on
[ __ ] you just joined a [ __ ]
I'd like to show you hey it's not
working very well it don't take much
damage from the knife
I think the shop shoot is supposed to
shoot oh oh you think yeah it's in the
name oh oh I never realized that oh god
you're so smart I'll do that oh you're
supposed to ah
so how do you read like a special perk
abilities whatever I don't know I think
it's just automatically applied okay
yeah I'm typing the charge on huh
stop doughnut right behind you they're
all over us just keep shooting
preferably in the head I'm almost out of
ammo I'm on my last magazine it's gotta
make them count
Boosh I still have it left don't worry
I've been kind of just spamming I'm
popping heads left and right two bullets
left behind me ah I'm bound to my knife
press Q to heal remember you can heal
like you don't really have med kits you
just gotta keep hitting whenever it
recharges on you oh that's really cool
actually
yep well inject south huh does take a
while there ah
rubella okay got my night uh I'm coming
towards you just walk towards the arrow
where the traitor is the knife is [ __ ]
we got to get closer to the grader
before we kill that last one where is it
anyway um there wasn't easy to follow
man there's a zombie what's here where'd
he go oh there it is he's limping along
oh no I'll kill him no but the Train
three were short of time do it man I got
it I got it yeah we go run run
is there a sprint huh
you think chef will be sprint but now I
think you just run faster with the knife
a la counter-strike mommy honey huh
judge Dragon Ball Z yeah I don't think
that helps you run faster anyway ah
alright hello hello okay
um oh and then I can't afford like dark
and or wheels that's something see all
right I'm feeling pretty confident right
now I don't want another shotgun did you
get the mac-10 that way yeah now I
didn't let me try that I don't think my
know that prize that's probably dumb
idea I tease cha I'm getting it
screw it I'm getting it and as much ammo
as I can oh this was a bad I felt like
poop yeah how dare you okay it smell get
away how dare you I think it's a dead
cow rotting over there but okay you can
blame it on me if you like all right I
got a magnet n which means lots of
bullets oh is that right yes
I guess head in the direction of the
other shop it is a horse it's supposed
to eat what's dead horses that's a cow
horse I was a cow that's a horse
is that a horse no I'm from America we
know our horses that is not as a cow huh
the whole sad is a cow I'm pretty sure
can tell by the long neck and oh my god
Ami's
you do wielding yes remember to aim for
the head
look up are you all right Mac ten times
I guess mr. Wang fine where are we
running 200 I got a lookout I'd you
invisible ones how do we turn it miss it
move I don't know they just always are
is this shoots a lot of bullets but it's
not very accurate nah sucks just keep
backing up man
I'll make sure our path is clear behind
us we're clear with clear and I'm ready
he'll UK algid do that if I was flying
right now I won behind us good feeling
real quick there we go back up back up
back up oh god I'm getting low Anana oh
god oh yeah broken Jeff yes he does he's
had one for a while okay I get back
enough just let's zoom around this
building seems to be pretty effective
hey we're doing pretty good not bad
don't get cocky kid every time I get
cocky I end up just dying yeah let's
survive at least two rounds oh god I got
five guys going now I gotta blast
magazines Oh up there coming from behind
I got aw it's just fantastic isn't it no
I cleared him out we're way far away
from the shop though so we may want to
consider going that way yeah that's just
till a couple more I'm completely out of
ammo though so I'm gonna go in this
house to try to find some good idea good
idea
Sani I'm going alone with my knife don't
worry about me I got it huh
you just go for the traitor man I'm
going towards the traitor then monitor
Oh No hey Nick hmm oh man no picnic
going on he'll Brighton all about the
bombing okay I got ammo head towards the
traitor
not much hop the mac-10 sucks
where are you he'll kill yummy hell you
barely dodged that rocket launcher
oh my god I hate these guys holy [ __ ]
okay it's just four zombies left all
right getting closer to the woman the
lovely lovely trader lady oh god your
health is low man
is there a heal thing q I suppose yeah
the other ones each edge zombies are way
back there I don't know where they are
okay MA dying mo ah help me man too bad
go oh wait I can heal you ready yeah
hang on come here well man you care of
those guys yeah I will heal you don't
get close to that one there we go I
healed you feel better now huh
yeah I feel great I can heal other
people more than I can here myself
ah I Love You Man you're welcome you
marry me no oh okay not legal in America
alright pretty close with the trainer we
could kill this guy okay you take care
of him why don't I take care of it cuz
you got the ammo I just got a knife
alright I don't use brave I guess no I'm
not that brave it's just done act I do
for my viewers don't tell them where is
this guy I don't know I think I found it
he's floating in the air kill him
God he's on the fence and he's humping
the fence yeah kill him
ah spy on me I'm okay I'm I try to sell
this mac-10 cuz it's sex
I'll be honest that was something else
um oh yeah oh yeah seeing that a zombie
was doing some crazy [ __ ] on offense and
see oh no time dual magnums oh man hey I
got quite a lot of money
all right fill ammo
Hans cannon oh it's just a pistol haha
this is it sounded pretty good it does
sound good it's a desert eagle I'm just
gonna get the bullpup see if I can get
him a little more accuracy on my machine
gun type deal you know I don't even know
if I want to buy anything
you better buy sell because we're not
doing so good in case you haven't
noticed you're ready to heal how did you
get hurt again take it again yes oh damn
it I remember if you apparently it's
better to heal each other than kill
yourself is that right how do I heal you
you just go to press five to pull it out
yeah yeah yeah put it up uh-huh they'll
just use it on me how do I do that kid
left click mm-hmm
hope you enjoyed that okay now see this
see this is exactly the same creatures
before and it's obviously a cow that
one's a cow but the other one was a hole
Oh so this one's a county other one
wasn't ah you don't you don't know what
you're talking about man
you go back through that recording you
will realize here they're coming through
the grass whoa what was that
I'm on fire what am I on fire the coop
down back up back up back up a lot
they don't even back up a lot oh nice
slo-mo is that activated by something or
that just random I found something
that's your ham that's ammo you're gonna
have that I got plenty
you got like a head shot me come on nice
huh no that was uh
maybe it's when you kill a lot of our
rocket launcher look out look out behind
you invisible one ah okay the boring pup
is much better I like this maybe if we
get like loads of kills it's just slime
eyes or something I don't know I don't
care so long as they die oh god man what
the hell haven't spot like a
straightjacket on what where oh that's
the that's the lady done let her get
close she's hidden sings you a song that
explodes your head really or something
like that I don't know - something like
that yeah
ah ooh she's really loud I know it
explodes your head I'm here oh my god
heal me I'll heal you will heal each
other one nice way machete my god ah why
have a machete about guys kill them kill
the heaven oh so scared
ow I'm gonna dives oh god it hurts so
bad all the invisible ones keep showing
themselves yet to you do they flash you
yeah yeah mark come here man
oh man I'm crouching at no.1 crouching
how just don't keep shooting um they
cannot move huh why are you stop
freaking crouching and move in injecting
you thank you
and again press the C button or
something and we're really far away from
the traitor again
shall we uh yeah yeah let's venture away
here I'll heal you now there we go yeah
I'm feeling much better uh somehow I
leveled up to level one of the medic
which I am NOT oh I see
good put the kaolinite the go on yeah
for the catalyzer
oh is that some British tea reference uh
yes oh yeah I was at fault I didn't
realize that was the last one you need
to be concentrated I am concentrating
what do you think I've been doing well
obviously not oh we're not gonna make it
man we're not gonna make it man
oh [ __ ] melody Dava okay just look in
buildings try to find ammo and in the
build things we're dead show do it the
train that trade it you got this hang on
I'm looking should be on this light
little mountain yeah I know
oh boy we're dead were dead we're not
gonna make it man I don't even know
where you went your fault don't my fault
what do you think you're talking about
stop my fault
hey hey I'm only looking out for our
best interests I'm gonna make it just in
time I'm gonna quit you why I'm having
them run out that's not gonna work man
okay uh I'm out did it yeah okay well
you're supporting me in this next round
okay wait I found me ammo inside a
building okay there's ammo next to me by
the way where um yeah I'm in the bill Oh
far more ammo all right that's good we
got this I'll know that they're spawning
they're all coming for them by the cow
where's the cow the cow out front and
buy it okay see you real closing so much
blood see see this was a horse
what know that Wow Wow come on everybody
everyone know out there knows it I doc
how I promise you I promise you promise
if that is a cow we're surrounded man
we're surrounding in the building for
tricky Monell um Oh head funnel them my
machine gun works best
uh huh now reloading get in the building
yeah die Wow
oh god no why not listen to you I got it
I got it you got it I don't got it I
don't got this is my last round for my
last clip ah oh oh
Joey shucks at this game maybe you suck
all is doing just fine
the only way to kill the last zombie
yeah so I was doing my job you obviously
don't know what you talked about fine oh
that's what you say anyway I guess
that's enough for now yeah well okay so
thank you everybody so much for watching
click the annotations and on yamimash
his face to go straight to his channel
we're gonna do another video a collab on
his channel so be sure to check it I'm
sure there will be a link somewhere
check the description or the annotation
soon thank you again and as always we
will see you in the next video
Oh
block door
love
Oh
yeah plain cool